die liste der zehn gefährlichsten drogen
jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
welche hre sind und wie sie wirken
basierend auf einem bericht des european
ratings und drums mit einem
überraschenden ergebnis
los geht's mit platz nummer 10
benzodiazepine auch bekannt als
tranquilizer medikamente mit diesen
pulli zyklischen organischen
verbindungen haben eine angstlösende und
muskelentspannende wirkung eigentlich
gut aber eingesetzt werden sie bei
patienten mit angststörungen oder
anderen spannungszustände in deutschland
leiden aber dann 1,1 millionen menschen
an einer benzodiazepinen abhängigkeit
bei einer überdosierung treten vermehrt
nebenwirkungen auf zb gedächtnisverlust
müdigkeit verminderte kritikfähigkeit
und abgestumpft gefühle auch beim vom
arzt verordneten dosen kann es zu einer
abhängigkeit kommen platz 9 liquid
ecstasy liquid ecstasy ist wie der name
schon sagt meist in flüssiger form
vorzufinden und sollte ursprünglich der
medizin dienen ähnlich wie die
benzodiazepine wirkt liquid ecstasy
beruhigend weshalb es in den 60er jahren
auch als narkosemittel eingesetzt wurde
von dem anästhetikum musste man sich
dann aber relativ schnell wieder trennen
da die nebenwirkungen wie motorische
störungen überhand nahm und nicht mehr
mit den medizinischen nutzen
gerechtfertigt werden konnten heute
kennt man liquid ecstasy leider viel
mehr als date rape drug mit der droge in
verbindung gebracht werden zahlreiche
vergewaltigungsfälle bei einer hohen
dosierung wird das mittel zu einer
starken beruhigung und sogar zu einer
bewusstlosigkeit
kommen wir zur platz nummer acht auch
diese droge wird medizinisch und zwar
heute immer noch eingesetzt
am geläufigsten ist marihuana weltweit
also die getrockneten blüten der pflanze
die dann geraucht werden obwohl man seit
den siebziger jahren versucht
herauszufinden welche wirkungen die
vielen inhaltsstoffe in cannabis im
körper haben hat man heute immer noch
nicht alles herausgefunden dass was man
weiß das gibt es übrigens in einem klick
zum video
nichtsdestotrotz steht kann ein bisschen
betäubungsmittelgesetz buch kurz btmg
wer also kann es sein eigen nennt in
größere mengen verkauft oder anpflanzt
macht sich strafbar
einzige ausnahme die so
cannabishaltige fertigarzneimittel die
etwa bei multipler sklerose eingesetzt
werden
bei der einnahme von cannabis kann es
auch zu entspannten zuständen
aber eben auch zu unwohlsein und
verwirrtheit kommen und auf platz sieben
der zehn gefährlichsten drogen
amphetamine zum beispiel speed sie
schütten im gehirn vermehrt das
glückshormon dopamin und das hormon
adrenalin aus beide hormone haben einen
großen einfluss auf das
belohnungszentrum so werden zustände von
selbstsicherheit und mut ausgelöst
allerdings gibt es auch nebenwirkungen
dazu gehören von bleibenden hirnschäden
mal abgesehen beispielsweise ein
fünffach erhöhtes herzinfarktrisiko und
starke psychosen sind wirklich
konsumenten neigen oft dazu ihre
körperlichen fähigkeiten zu überschätzen
durch die vermeintlich große
leistungsbereitschaft des körpers kann
es schnell zur erschöpfung kommen eine
steigerung der dosis kann dann zur
überhitzung des körpers führen zu den
amphetaminen gehört übrigens auch das
häufig bei aufmerksamkeitsdefizit
hyperaktivitätssyndrom adhs verschrieben
ritalin auf dem sechsten platz treffen
wir auf eine sehr weit verbreitete droge
tabak eine der wenigen legalen drogen
auf unserer liste jedes jahr sterben
sechs millionen menschen weltweit an den
folgen von tabakkonsum nikotin ist ein
sehr schnell abhängig machen dass stoff
und stimuliert ähnlich wie kokain und
amphetamine durch rauchen kann es zu
einer vielzahl von gesundheitsproblemen
kommen da wären zum beispiel ein
erhöhtes risiko von krebs in lunge mund
rachen speiseröhre magen niere und blase
bei hohen dosen kann der konsum von
tabak auch zu psychosen führen zur fünf
gefährlichsten drogen haben schon die
inkas gegriffen kokain durch das weiße
pulver werden die hormone dopamin
noradrenalin und serotonin ausgeschüttet
es kann zur zerebralen krampfanfällen
oder sogar zum proma kommen
nach dem abklingen einer positiven
wirkung kann es auch zur paranoiden
angstzuständen kommen auch hier kann der
konsum der droge zu einer überlastung
des körpers führen da dessen leistung
überschätzt wird die folgen können
herzinfarkt oder einem kreislaufversagen
besonders gefährlich macht die
abhängigkeit von kokain
diese äußert sich nämlich nur in
psychischer und nicht in physischer form
was aber ebenfalls nicht zu
unterschätzen ist noch gefährlich aber
das auf platz vier methamphetamin oder
auch christof küster märz ist wohl erst
nach serien wie breaking bad so richtig
in die öffentliche wahrnehmung gerückt
entwickelt wurde die droge im jahr noch
zwei 34 und kam erstmal unter dem namen
pervitin auf dem markt bei wien war bis
in die 80er jahre als medikament
erhältlich aufgrund der nebenwirkung
wurde es aus dem verkehr gezogen die
nebenwirkung ähneln denen der
amphetamine sind aber in ihrer
intensität weitaus schlimmer es steigert
das sexuelle verlangen mindert aber
gleichzeitig die sexuelle
leistungsfähigkeit der missbrauch von
methamphetamin kann unter anderem zu
paranoiden verhalten nierenschäden
nervenschäden gewichtsverlust
aggressiven verhalten einbußen der
gedächtnisleistung und nicht zuletzt dem
verlust der zähne führen
letzteres geschieht übrigens weil der
speichelfluss im mund gehemmt wird und
küsste konsumenten zu zähneknirschen
neigen
die droge wird auch auf tampa thies
eingesetzt kommen wir in die top 3 auf
dem dritten platz befindet sich greg
craig wird aus kokain salz natron und
wasser hergestellt
nachdem diese zutaten vermischt und
erhitzt werden bleibt das gelbliche
crack übrig diese gelblichen stückchen
werden lange in einer zigarette oder
einer wasserpfeife inhaliert und dadurch
sehr schnell nämlich schon nach zehn
sekunden im blut aufgenommen
allerdings wirkt es auch nur fünf bis
zehn minuten weg soll die stimmung heben
die nebenwirkung für die konsumenten
können psychosen schizophrenie und
angstzustände seien die droge kann zu
einem herzstillstand führen und zudem
hat weg das höchste
abhängigkeitspotenzial aller drogen und
das ist die zweit gefährlichste droge
heroin in der chemie wird heroin als 3,5
die acetyl offen bezeichnet als
entwicklung der pharmaindustrie bei
heroin zunächst ein schmerzmittel der
pharmakonzern bayer verkauft um 1900
heroin als mittel gegen schmerzen und
husten
es ist ein analgetische opioid das
bedeutet so viel wie dem opium ähnlich
opiate hingegen sind aber rein
typische stoffe heute ist sehr ruhig
eine der gefährlichsten drogen die
gefahr geht nicht nur von den negativen
auswirkungen das heroin selbst aus es
kann beispielsweise zu atemstillstand
führen sondern auch durch die art des
konsums heroin wird meistens gespritzt
und dabei treten häufig hygienische
mängel auf sie übertragen sich hepatitis
oder hiv von einem anwender zum nächsten
das wird komorbidität genannt
begleiterkrankungen die droge selbst
führt zu keinen schäden an organen
allerdings ist die gefahr einer
überdosierung sehr hoch auch die
persönlichkeit eines heroinabhängigen
kann sich stark verändern die droge
wirkt sich auf den kreislauf aus kann
diesen verlangsamen und so wie schon
erwähnt zum herzstillstand führen auch
die atemwege können versagen was zu den
meisten todesfällen führt da der körper
schnell eine toleranz gegen den stoff
aufbaut muss die dosis erhöht werden um
die wirkung weiter spürbar zu machen und
das ist die top nummer eins
gefährlichste droge der welt ich selbst
habe ich ihr schon einmal in einem
selbstversuch gestellt und musste einen
echten dreh miterleben es geht um die
legale droge alkohol
der link zum videos und in der video
beschreibung die risiken durch den
konsum beginnen bei dem leichtsinnigem
verhalten im rausch bis hin zum
komasaufen was zu einer tödlichen
alkoholvergiftung führen kann alkohol
ist immer noch eine unterschätzte droge
teilweise setzten sich er ja schon
zwölfjährige kinder illegaler weise der
coolness halber dem nervengift aus
allerdings ist das risiko auf
folgeschäden immens schon bei 0,2
promille beginnt das gehirn damit
entfernung falsch einzuschätzen
diesen wert erreicht ein 80 kilogramm
schwerer mann fast schon durch einen
viertelliter bier
mit fünf prozent alkohol der entfernung
falsch einschätzt wird für sich und
andere zur gefahr ebenso leitet das
reaktionsvermögen dazu kommt dass
alkohol so gut wie alle organe des
menschlichen körpers schädigt angefangen
bei der leber in der sich tumore bilden
können dem gehirn herz haut alles ist
betroffen
durch die schäden am gehirn kann ein
langanhaltender alkoholkonsum zu einer
demenz erkrankung führen auch
persönlichkeitsveränderungen sind die
folge alkohol ist also wie ich finde
absolut berechtigt auf platz eins der
gefährlichsten drogen und was meint ihr
stellt doch mal eure eigene liste auf in
den kommentaren und diskutiert mit uns
über den european rating und jörg harms
bericht wenn euch das video gefallen hat
dann lasse
gerne einen daumen nach oben hier
vergesst nicht den kanal kostenlos zu
abonnieren
wer sich mein selbstversuch jetzt noch
angucken will der kann hier oben und ami
klicken da findet ihr das video und
unsere best auf klicks und playlist
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran